where at first all motorbike just
looking at magnets like when are you
gonna design boy but Magnus could resign
it at any moment
yeah
that Death Stare look at that it's not
often you see someone eyeballing Magnus
Carlson and uh he's not
he's not looking away you see I I mean
the game is over
[Music]
uh
and he is enjoying every second of the
sipping on his drink I always like to
point out that when somebody drinks
water during a game that generally means
they're satisfied with their position
that means they have the mental capacity
to focus on their beverage and their
snack and The Spectators anything but
the board because he has it all figured
out